j'aime beaucoup ma chronique parce
qu'elle est excellente mais j'aime aussi
celle de camille combal et il ya
quelques temps dans l'émission dans sa
chronique qui nous avait montré un petit
garçon qui faisait un petit peu l'idiot
en faisant batman oui au jour du
seigneur ont regardé pour ceux qui
savent et revienne pas est pas si le
père viendra les vivants et les morts je
crois
alors
eh bien
mais poser
[Applaudissements]
ouais l'armée oui amis des petites
recherches il s'appelle baptiste et il
est avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
bon allez bertreau tu me laisses ta
place place aux jeunes
[Applaudissements]
allez vas tu lis qu'il a parlé du show
avec nous moi j'avais un petit peu de
vélo et les efad nettoyage et si c'est
pour vivre mal commencée avec la claque
visuelle de ce début d'année oublier
avatar gravity et transformers à l'usure
et de passer devant le compteur est à
plat
[Applaudissements]
on est on est en direct ont même refusé
on est diffusée cette émission pas tout
à fait bah écoutez vous devriez un petit
peu plus le travail commence à vatry
saint-jean-baptiste que tu as dix ans
oui c'est ça dont on compte à découvert
la semaine dernière dans ses mains tu
travailles bien oui c'est vrai tu
regarde souvent les missions oui c'est
vrai qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui c'est
qui et ont préféré dans l'émission bas
et les palaces et enora c'est une aura
bon allez l'acl
mettez un sexe continue cyrine on dirais
tu fais pas ci plus du tout on dirait
pakistanais que c'est qu'ils font des
pousse pousse
[Applaudissements]
donc on fait donc et jean claude volot
voix pakistanais c'est normal des
mercury aller
[Applaudissements]
sa trop longue pas parce qu'on va perdre
le vieux que c'est quand même d'acheter
une question si moi je rame pendant
incroyable ça rapporte tout s'emballe
c'est un peu dans les loges qui a été le
plus gentil avec toi moi la vérité le
plus gentil toi voilà là on voit les
lycées mais c'est énorme je donne et
ceintures rouges qui a été le moins
sympa dit franchement celui du talent
moi parler dans les logs celui que tu es
taya qui était loin sympa avec toi le le
plus méchant c'est celui que j'ai vu lé
mois ouais mais celui thème celui qui a
été moins sympa avec toi tu peux dire
personne personne au monde a été
gentiment on a juste donné 5 euros
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que le ps quelque chose assez
magique oui c'est universel le psc1 tu
peux péter au cameroun en suède
ça fait rire footeux comprendre quelque
chose qui réunit lé p c'est important de
le dire mais je suis sûr que ce couple
s'est mis ensemble oif
vous n'êtes pas pour la paix dans le
monde mais pour le pédalier et moi y'a
papy qui veut parler oui c'est pas pour
rien que conspirateurs premier rendez
vous ont dit on se prend un vent c'est
la société sahraouie
il a tapé telle ambiance
allez un peu de vélo pour les deux et la
qualité va venir dont il paraît que ça
fait péter en plus donc à oui vous savez
vous m'avez dit je la sens pas celle là
je dis ça vaut mieux donc pas de là je
t'apporte l'histoire y arriver au
théâtre il faisait systématiquement un
groupe et il se tourner vers sa voisine
que ça fait rien madame vous n'aurez
qu'à dire que c'est moi ça va être sympa
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire du fort du store
c'est que tu vois le drame c'est comme
s'il était au volant mais c'est sa voix
mûre arriver dès jeudi
ça va y aller le dos reis m el hiba
quand je sens la seule salle